[Música]
[Aplausos]
el país Vasco una tierra con carácter
entre el mar y las montañas con una
gastronomía que enorgullece a su gente
el país Vasco cuenta con nada menos que
12 restaurantes con estrellas michelán
nacidos del maridaje entre productos
locales y el saber hacer de los mejores
chefs vascos
en San Champion los compradores
frecuentes del mercado reconocen
fácilmente al chef Philip
casi como un ritual él viene a elegir
uno a uno los productos para su cocina
sirvo fritos de ají si los ají son
demasiados pequeños se desintegran si
son demasiado Grandes como esta nos
hablando en lo suficiente entre los dos
es perfecto por eso es bueno acudir al
mercado
Aquí es donde se encuentra con este fan
su horticultor biológico con el que
trabaja desde hace años también necesito
Flores Flores comestibles
estar cerca de sus productos es
importante recojo las cosas y una hora
después están en el restaurante de
philippe
totalmente fresco si le falta algo me
llama y le recojo más y la ventaja para
mí es que es mi catador y uno bueno
además por ejemplo tenía tres variedades
que serían buenas para las papas fritas
Así que le di una muestra de cada uno a
Philip que lo probó y me dijo Cuál eran
entonces puedo decir a mis clientes
estos han sido fritos y probados por
arrambit así que usa estos Y es que el
apellido a jambit es conocido en todo el
país Vasco como una dinastía de grandes
chefs la historia se remonta a 1939
cuando la familia convirtió el hotel de
pianine una antigua posada en una
institución gastronómica firmina figura
emblemática de la cocina francesa y
padre de philippe obtuvo su primera
estrella micheland en 1975 y la segunda
10 años más tarde creo que nuestra labor
es apoyar y promocionar los productos
Auténticos como los hermosos champiñones
blancos de nuestra región nuestros
corderos que corren libres por las
laderas Y si los cocineros no somos los
principales Defensores de esta tradición
entonces creo que se extinguirá formado
por su padre philippe tomó las riendas y
ha añadido su propio toque moderno pero
sin alejarse de la clásica comida local
aún hoy la palombo capuzón el célebre
plato de Paloma torcaz de agambit forma
parte del menú
soy la cuarta generación Así que para mí
es algo totalmente natural
desde que era pequeño he entrado en la
cocina y he visto palomas torcaces
tenemos una forma especial de cocinarlos
la sellamos y asamos como para cualquier
plato de ave pero justo antes de
servirlas las flameamos con grasa de
tocino a través de inflamadura
la grasa gotea sobre la paloma torcaz
dándole ese sabor especial
Aunque la tradición vasca ocupa aquí un
lugar de honor lo haces Siempre con
ganas de sorprender
mi cocina evoluciona bastante en
realidad Porque me gusta tener un menú
totalmente nuevo cada año y olvidar lo
que hice el año anterior
siempre estoy evolucionando en los
platos en la presentación en los Sabores
en las técnicas
es una parte importante de nuestra
profesión
otro de los chefs con estrella micheland
de la región es cedric Vasco de adopción
estos necesitarán otros dos meses entre
la floración y el fruto pasan dos meses
natural de la región de limosau decidió
trasladarse aquí por su amor a los
productos locales hoy visita a su
pimentero de spelet uno de mis
principales criterios para venir aquí es
el contacto con el productor y el
producto porque los chefs no somos nada
sin los productores y sus productos el
ají despelet es el oro rojo del país
Vasco es más conocido en forma de polvo
de guindilla pero para cedric este
producto tradicional sigue teniendo la
capacidad para sorprender te imaginas un
plato y luego ves algo en la página de
tu productor Y dices Ah sí es una idea
pero se necesitan 10 ideas para dar con
una buena incluso mientras trabajas en
ello no estás seguro de que vaya a
terminar en algo con las cosas que haces
bien también puedes tener sorpresas es
una ají realmente equilibrado es picante
pero tiene un toque terroso pero el
calor no es como el de los piripiris que
te hacen llorar los ojos
creo que exploraremos esto un poco más
explorar es una de las pasiones de
cedric siempre está dispuesto a salir de
su posada vasca para ir al encuentro de
su productor de queso o Cordero
a 100 kilómetros en un culo a 1.300
metros de altitud un rebaño de 300
ovejas aprovecha al máximo los pastos de
montaña
[Música]
es el mejor queso del mundo no sé en el
mundo pero en el país Vasco seguro qué
bien huele porque este paso está lleno
de leguminosas en lo alto de las
montañas Las ovejas pasen en los ricos
pastos de los pirineos vascos también se
ordeñan a mano y los quesos se dejan
madurar mucho tiempo para producir un
Steve con Sabores excepcionales cedric
es el portavoz autoproclamado de este
saber hacer tradicional tenemos que
apoyar y promover los conocimientos
técnicos que hay detrás de nuestros
alimentos es algo que Hemos descuidado
un poco el planeta es el primer eslabón
de la cadena luego están los productores
y sus productos y después nosotros
formamos parte de la cadena así que
tenemos un deber que cumplir o con la
definición desde productos locales hasta
cenas con estrellas micheland los chefs
del país Vasco son sus mejores
Embajadores
[Música]